[Musique]
cette année la vedette incontestable du
salon c'est un modèle qui réconcilie le
meilleur des deux mondes
c'est à dire un v ux et un véhicule
électrique et ses lames hosting
n'acquittent de fort
l'autonomie maximale va frôler les 500
kilomètres pour ce qui est de l'échelle
de prix us a varié entre 50000 et 83
mille dollars
la mac y est au centre de la stratégie
de ford qui veulent investir 11
milliards de dollars d'ici 2022 dans
l'électrification de toute sa gamme de
modèles cette année le parcours commence
avec la zone électrique ce qui en soi
est une affirmation faut savoir que le
québec est le sixième marché mondial
pour le véhicule électrique seulement au
canada
50 % des voitures électriques sont
vendus au pays sont vendus au québec
le mitsubishi outlander phv était
jusqu'à maintenant le seul des verrues s
contact
offert en version hybride rechargeable
mais depuis cette année ce n'est plus le
cas il ya un peu perdu son monopole
puisque cette année ford propose une
version hybride rechargeable de son
escape refait de a à z
toyota aussi cette année propose une
version hybride rechargeable de son rav4
le rav4 prime et même super u bonifier
son offre avec la crosse trek qui est
affaire de cette année en version
hybride rechargeable ou enfichable
[Musique]
les enfants n'essayez pas ceux ci à la
maison alors exactement vingt ans après
la résurrection du nom min on offre
cette année une mini cooper électrique
qui vient étoffer une gamme qui est déjà
assez variés acquis et seulement trois
modèles mais qui se décline en une
multitude de versions il demeure
l'élément clé quand on parle de
véhicules électriques c'est l'autonomie
dans ce cas ci on nous promet une
autonomie de 200 km
jusqu'à maintenant la model s de tesla
n'avait pas de rival à cette époque est
révolue parce que c'est porsche qui
vient de riposter en premier avec la
taille kahn qui est une voiture très
rapide comme la tesla
on nous promettait une autonomie
comparable au six à de ce côté là il ya
une déception
463 km s'est nettement en deçà des 600
km de la tesla
les prix sont stratosphériques on
commence à sembler mais le dollar
et ça peut atteindre facilement 200
mille dollars audi volvo et tesla sont
les trois principaux absents cette année
au salon de montréal et vous connaissez
le dicton 1
les absents ont toujours tort puisque
regardez ici au salon de l'auto de
montréal
bon an mal an c'est toujours autour de
deux cent mille personnes qui visitent
le salon
[Musique]
même la ford modèle t présente au salon
de tout ce qui est un juste retour des
choses puisque c'est vraiment la voiture
qui a démocratisé l'automobile chez les
japonais comme chez les autres
constructeurs
les vo us sont en train de remplacer les
voitures on en est pas encore là chez
mazda mais il ya quand même un nouveau
venu est ce qui s'ajoute cette année le
cx 30 qui vient s'intercaler entre le
cx3 et le cx-5 ce comme un médium qui
aurait rétréci au lavage d'une année à
l'autre les v ux compaq ont tellement
grossi qui a fallu créer une nouvelle
catégorie les v ux sous compacte hyundai
avait déjà son kona on en ajoute un
nouveau cette année un autre but est
sous compacte sauf que lui n'a que deux
roues motrices et celles ayant des
veniot dans l'univers des vo us
lucky hasselt hausse est un autre
nouveau joueur c'est le jumeau ou le
clown appelez ça comme vous voulez du
lion des connards et oui encore un autre
virus dans la gamme de volkswagen la
classe sport se situe exactement entre
le tiguan et la place donc c'est le
médium du trio
il ya pas beaucoup de légendes vivantes
dans l'automobile mais ça c'en est une
la chevrolet corvette qui fête ses 67
ans en grand pour la première fois de
son histoire échange des architectures
complètement avec un moteur qui est
désormais placé en position centrale
arrière
le but de l'exercice c'est qu'on veut
compétitionner directement avec porsche
et avec ferrari et comme toujours avec
la corvette pour une fraction du prix
parce qu'à 70 mille dollars comme prix
de départ c'est quand même la moitié
d'une porsche et le tiers d'une ferrari
alors oui il reste encore des autos au
salon de l'auto il n'y a pas juste des
vo us
ce que vous voyez à côté de moi c'est la
sentra si vous avez l'impression de voir
une altimo qui aurait passé dans la
sécheuse
c'est pas loin de la vérité elles sont
très semblables à cintra et un plus
petit c'est une compacte et d'ailleurs
avec cette voiture nissan espère revenir
en force dans le segment des compactes
pour affronter des modèles très
populaires comme la honda civic la mazda
3 ou encore la lionne des landes bon
salon 2020 et bonne route
[Musique]